mais sur ta fille à faire des des
demandes pour des dépenses qui n'étaient
pas des dépenses des vraies dépenses
c'est peut-être ma joe wright qui était
à la barre des témoins mais si stephen
harper dont on fait le procès
aujourd'hui les canadiens se doivent
on le droit de s'attendre à ce que leur
premier ministre son bureau leur dise la
vérité à la place est devenu très clair
qu'ils ont choisi de dissimuler la
vérité la réalité qu'il y a deux
personnes responsables
ils sont les supérieurs sur wright
monsieur d'affilée ils sont en train
d'être tenir responsables pour leur
section monsieur moines caire par son
texte un gros projet novaïa 10 km ces
candidats au québec faisait un nombre
non le cadre on vérifie win win win dans
l'eau non c'est pas mal traduction est
un projet comme énergie est va reprendre
en vertu d'un processus crédible et
complexes propres à un gouvernement
conservateur réélu fera en sorte que le
fait de se rendre à des endroits
désignés par le gouvernement comme étant
des foyers d'activité terroriste sera
infraction criminelle
la réalité c'est que le canada c'est un
pays qui défend les droits des individus
et quand un gouvernement veut limiter
ses droits il se doit de répondre à bien
plus de questions que ce que monsieur
harper a répondu ce matin
l'abolition de stations que chanter est
ma d'accord avec son opposition aux
décisions arbitraires de canet passe
canada qui ne respecte absolument le
paysage urbain
c'est sympa de sens quant à la manière
dont moi je prends de nos tropiques à
genoux